[Musique]
alors un tiers de missile russe a
gravement endommagé une clinique d'aide
psychologique de ni pro dans le centre
de l'Ukraine vous les voyez ces images
l'attaque a fait deux morts grande
blessés dont certains sont dans un état
critique l'armée russe dit plutôt avoir
détruit un entrepôt de munitions c'est
toujours l'explication mais après 15
mois de guerre en Ukraine les
bombardements et les infiltrations se
sont multipliées ces derniers mois sur
le territoire économique bien sûr mais
aussi du côté russe on a vécu ces
derniers jours envoyer spécial du
magazine de français le point anniva est
de retour d'un séjour de plusieurs
semaines en Russie mais elle va souvent
et longtemps en Russie on a plaisir de
la retrouver à New York univa bonsoir
bienvenue 24h
écoutez c'est assez privilégié de vous
accueillir et d'avoir votre regard sur
ce que vous avez vu lors de ce plus
récent séjour qui vient de se terminer
donc vous avez fait le récit dans le
magazine Le Point parce que vous avez
fait aussi une incursion en Tchétchénie
les guerres que vous aviez
couvertes à l'époque alors est-ce qu'on
peut avoir le pouls c'est possible de
dire de l'humeur des Russes en ce moment
vous avez même tweeté c'est comme si
pour Poutine la guerre n'existait pas ou
comme s'il voulait faire comme si elle
n'existait pas
d'abord je voudrais préciser que je vais
dans la guerre des deux côtés c'est à
dire j'ai été aussi sur le terrain et
sur le front en Ukraine pour le point et
maintenant je vais du côté russe parce
que c'est plus difficile d'aller du côté
russe il y a moins d'autorisation et
comme c'est la Russie quand même
l'assaillant l'attaquant si je puis dire
c'est comme c'est intéressant d'essayer
de comprendre ce qui s'y passe alors
pour répondre à votre question qui est
une question vaste je dirais en deux
mots que la guerre devient de plus en
plus disons
occupe de plus en plus l'esprit des
Russes elle l'occupe parce que ça les
gêne il y a un sentiment de colère
puisque les Russes se rendent quand même
bien compte malgré toute la propagande
que leur armée n'arrive pas à gagner
cette guerre donc ils sont en colère et
puis il y a un sentiment de honte aussi
lié au fait que leur armée n'arrive pas
à la gagner et un sentiment d'insécurité
grandissant puisque comme vous venez de
le dire il y a maintenant et ça fait
partie bien sûr de la stratégie tous
azimut de guerre hybride menée par les
Ukrainiens de leur contre-offensive
disons d'incursion sur le territoire
fédéral russe même si la Russie est
gigantesque et que ces incursions pour
le moment ne concerne que la partie qui
est la plus proche de l'Ukraine en même
temps on est à la veille de cette
contre-fensive
ukrainienne semble-t-il il y a des
indices de cela mais vu de Russie au vu
de Tchétchénie parce que vous avez
rencontré Kadirov qui est ma foi est-ce
qu'on pas le bras droit
pour Poutine mais en lien avec le peuple
tchétchène qui a vécu ces deux guerres
puis certaine comparaison à faire avec
l'Ukraine parce que
ce sont des images pour le point en
train d'interviewer Ramzan Kadirov qui
est un dictateur mais qui est si vous
voulez autoriser par le pouvoir russe
puisque la Tchétchénie fait partie de
l'immense Fédération de Russie et
cet homme est le fils de son père son
père avait également été le président de
la Tchétchénie son père avait été
assassiné en 2004 et c'est suite à
l'assassinat de son père que cet homme a
pris sa suite à partir de 2004 on est
quand même aujourd'hui
plus de 20 ans plus tard et il est
toujours au pouvoir donc l'effet de
chaîne il y a des sentiments ambivalents
du peuple tchétchène par rapport à
Moscou et par rapport à la guerre en
Ukraine en un mot parce que c'est
compliqué je vais j'essaie de vous
expliquer
moi qui voyage dans toute la Fédération
de Russie j'ai jamais vu une région de
Russie qui est autant Ant
pourquoi ils sont anti-guerre
anti-guerre en Ukraine je veux dire ils
sont anti-guerre parce que eux-mêmes les
Tchétchènes ont subi deux guerres de
leurs petites République contre la
Fédération de Russie il n'y a pas si
longtemps la première fois entre 94 et
96 et la deuxième fois de 99 à 2009 donc
la guerre si vous voulez encore dans
tous les esprits mais en même temps
la Russie qui a détruit la Tchétchénie
comme elle est en train de détruire
l'Ukraine a également ensuite
reconstruit là-dessus de chez nous et
c'est pour ça que ramsane kadirof arrive
aujourd'hui à tenir son pays si vous
voulez parce que
la paix antiphennie aujourd'hui est dû à
tout l'argent que le Kremlin que Moscou
verse à la suite on va avoir à l'esprit
la différence alors la comparaison va te
grossnik avait été détruite et là
backmouth détruit Mario Paul détruit on
se demandera qui qui va reconstruire je
vais vous parler de privilégier une qui
est l'autre
les méthodes russes là
parce qu'encore aujourd'hui vous dans
les dernières heures il y a déclaré qui
faites attention les élites russes les
prêts à y avoir une révolution en Russie
il nargue le pouvoir de Poutine avec
quelles conséquences selon vous
oui oui cet homme est venu Prigogine
nargue le pouvoir vous avez raison de le
dire mais il faut quand même expliquer
qui est pris gojin Prigogine est un
homme qui n'existerait pas dans les
médias
occidentaux
sans cette guerre en Ukraine donc alors
que Kadirov dont je viens de parler
existe auparavant comme je l'ai expliqué
donc autant qu'à dire of si vous voulez
est un pur produit du système et du
pouvoir russe autant il y a gagné
Prigogine est un pur produit qui ne sort
pas du système donc c'est un homme
d'affaires en premier lieu et c'est un
homme d'affaires qui prend qui tire
profit de la guerre en Ukraine justement
par ces liens avec l'ennemire Poutine il
avait promis à Vladimir Poutine sans
donner de date qu'il gagnerait une
grosse bataille en Ukraine il a gagné
c'est celle de darkmouth et aujourd'hui
si vous voulez il est intouchable donc
malgré toutes ces critiques si vous
voulez toutes ces diatribe anti-pouvoirs
mais jamais anti Poutine directement
ministre de la Défense etc il n'importe
qui d'autre n'aurait pas le droit de les
faire n'importe qui d'autre serait jeté
en prison en Russie pour ce genre de
propos et bien pas lui parce que le
pouvoir lui pardonne tout ou plutôt
Vladimir Poutine lui-même lui pardonne
tout grâce à cette victoire à barthout
là-dessus univers c'est on va cesser
là-dessus mais j'invite les gens aller
vous lire dans le magasin le point et
essayer de lire votre ouvrage dans la
gueule du loup publier en 2021 et c'est
une bande dessinée c'est il faut surtout
lire un autre ouvrage qui est publié
après et qui s'appelle qui est sur la
sur la Russie un continent derrière
Poutine et puis surtout faudra lire mon
prochain ouvrage que je vais bientôt
écrire alors j'espère qu'on pourra oui
mais on vous donne alors on espère vous
recevoir à ce moment aller peut-être
bien avant on va vous laisser le temps
de l'écrire et puis c'est un éclairage
complètement inédit que vous nous avez à
faire ce soir alors on l'apprécie
vivement merci bonne soirée bon séjour à
New York au revoir